o douro é objetos que falam nos últimos
anos muitos dos objetos do nosso dia a
dia têm vindo a incorporar tecnologia de
comunicação sem fios
o prêmio que nos comuniquem o que falem
com os nossos telemóveis tablets e
computadores
na prática isto serve serve por exemplo
para que nós através do nosso tablet
possamos mudar a cor das nossas lâmpadas
por exemplo se tivermos um jantar
romântico podemos pôr uma sala mais
avermelhada podemos tivermos de jogar
futebol por um terá uma sala mais
razoável pra mim por exemplo
interagirmos com portas e inteligente
forma automática as portas teto que o
dono da casa está a aproximar e abrem
automaticamente para o dono entrar
isto pode dar jeito por exemplo é que os
casos é que vocês estão super carregados
com compras e não conseguem encontrar as
chaves estão então deixar que tudo a
portar sozinha também pode ser útil para
que o colega quarto não paga renda
estamos a mudar a fechadura chegamos a
lei tiramos a autorização do telemóvel é
esse objeto também estará informação
sobre o mundo que nos rodeia a
informação em tempo real
neste caso prático temos um vaso tem um
sensor que não tive informação em tempo
real para o telemóvel sobre o estado
daquela planta portanto nós estamos na
sala sentadas relaxados e de repente
recebemos uma notificação no telemóvel a
dizer nos pa
a plantinha no fundo fumar nos dizer é
pastor que sozinha por favor vai me
ligar a tecnologia nem sempre é um caso
prático thater já muita zero ou seja o
que eu tô aqui apresentar não são coisas
o tópico é de e ficção científica este
caso já existe há muitos museus aplicar
esta tecnologia aos seus quadros
isto permitiu que quando o visitante vai
ao museu sacaca do seu telemóvel da
aplicação do museu e aplicação ou
telemóvel da pessoa detecta
automaticamente o quadro que está à
frente do visitante e disponibiliza
informação sobre esse quadro e esquadro
automaticamente muito útil
muitos nós já estivemos no museu é
imenso tempo a esperar na fila para usar
um de eurico lara que traduzo que quer a
plaquinha do quadro disse
chegamos chamas já a senhora olha não
recuarem em português
não temos só o italiano espanhol e
mandarim tanto é que pode ser resolvido
esse problema porque o telemóvel tenha
as nossas missões sabe a nossa língua e
os conteúdos gerados é nosso e agora que
você já sabe imenso de objetos inclui
gente e comunicação objetos com o
telemóvel e computador
vamos então subir aqui o nível e vamos
pensar então se um telemóvel consegue
interagir com o objeto
então quer dizer que um amigo meu pode
mandar a casa do computador dell via
internet
um comando para o meu telemóvel por sua
vez vai interagir com objetos ou seja
via internet é possível hoje em dia é
ser enviar comandos pedra objetos
isto permite coisas muito engraçadas
depois que vamos ver neste vídeo esta
motoqueira vos quero mostrar
é o telê que é tê-lo agora quando chove
porque não seu sutiã
ele é que está em cannes liberação são
ativados por telemóvel
então mas essas coisas são tão
interessantes porque só agora é que
aparece ora nestes últimos dois anos
sensivelmente acima tudo por causa do
aparecimento de uma tecnologia como é
normal nestas coisas esta tecnologia se
chama se luto low energy ou é de baixo
consumo e baixo consumo quer dizer que
podemos trabalhar com pilhas ou baterias
muito reduzidas portanto esta tecnologia
pode ser incorporada nos objetos por
exemplo uma sapatilha seria aumentar o
tamanho ou prejudicar a estética está
uma coisa importante não destruir a
verdadeira natureza do objeto ok essa
tecnologia é mais o custo por problemas
de incorporá las em fazer com que o
preço do objeto chuva significativamente
e projetar aqui as coisas a partir de
2011 e 2012
os grandes fabricantes de telemóveis
acharam que esta tecnologia vale a pena
portanto começaram a votar massivamente
portanto 2013 2014 foi época em que esta
tecnologia com sua familiar ia ser
aplicado a muitos objetos e agora é até
agora temos estado a falar de coisas
parecem mais malucas que outra coisa
mais entretenimento mas a verdade é que
a área da internet das coisas dos
objetos inteligentes também pode
resolver problemas que têm um grande
impacto na nossa vida e que tem um
impacto econômico e o impacto um
sentimental também por exemplo nos
estados unidos perdem todos os
aeroportos 80 milhões de malas por ano
quero uma custar 100 euros o valor da
mala mas o seu conteúdo estamos a falar
de 80 8 mil milhões
fora no caso dos cães e gatos não
precisamos traduzir para mim eram todos
nós sabemos o amor que temos pelos
nossos animais de estimação e nós
queremos poder é esse problema
é nesse problema que eu ea minha equipe
trabalhamos é esse problema tentamos
resolver utilizando então a área dos
objetos e inteligente e de internet das
coisas
resolvemos isto criamos um pequeno
dispositivo chama lapa lapa por causa do
animal apa escola as coisas é é um
sensor de proximidade escolas nossos
projetos para que eles possam ser
localizadas através do telemóvel é um
setor muito pequenino com menos três
centímetros raia um pouco mais de meio
milímetro de altura funciona com uma
pilha de relógio até oito meses uma
pilha minúscula e basicamente transpõe
para os objetos a lógica do dar um toque
ou seja é um objecto consiga através da
aplicação saber a distância de tonel e
posso dar um toque fácil quando pega o
telemóvel
temos mais outras brincadeiras já volta
visto desde então aqui um pequeno vídeo
só para perceberem como é que nós
resolvemos melhora este problema do da
localização de objetos perdidos lapa e
design vai estar outlook e hortênsias em
um chimarrão
walk to be alone sonho que milagres é de
que o ida banho lavar o barril em
flushing cep bosque napoli everton lapa
que me dei bem vai ter de ganhar e agora
para ter uma noção da bp para concluir
neste momento a imensa de equipas como
nós estão a trabalhar na área da
internet das coisas e dos objetos de
inteligência é uma coisa que não vai
parar em 2020 estima se que vai haver 5
50 mil milhões de objetos conectados à
internet
o que é interessante nesta área que
muitas das coisas que vocês pensam que
são coisas do futuro do futuro distante
a ficção científica já são presente e
vão existir é um forno que aquece a
comida de nós quer se apresentar antes
de nós chegarmos de casa temos lá
quentinha
já existe um carro que nós abrimos para
vir ter connosco e eu vai ter connosco
sem condutor sozinho já existe não é o
que dizem frases motivacionais para os
padrões puxar nosso exercício físico já
existe
jorge já visto é portanto uma coisa
estou certo não são aplicadas mas uma
coisa estou certo é viagem do presidente
o futuro nesta área está cada vez mais
rápida
portanto aperte os cintos aqui vamos nós